I think Carnegie Mellon can play a key
role in solar technology
we can make plastics that conduct
electricity
or absorb light from the Sun and turn
the light into electricity now the power
of that is that you can make that you
can dissolve these plastics just like
you can dissolve any plastics and then
you can make any shape or form out of
them so you can print them you can do
roll-to-roll printing you can print it
essentially like a newspaper because you
can make an ink and so the technology
will be incredibly cheap if you can
imagine literally going to home depot
and buying just sheets of plastic that
they could tear off that basically you
give to the person who cleans your
windows who would just install these
into your windows so that you would have
electricity in your homes that is
basically integrated into your windows
and if I had on my blackberry simply
coated with a plastic that was a solar
charger then I would never have to worry
about ever charging it so we could just
revolutionize the world through off-grid
portable lightweight solar power and
these were technologies that were
created at Carnegie Mellon